[Music]
ladies and gentlemen give it up for your
headliner Josh
[Applause]
[Music]
Wolf yes super what's going on everybody
yeah I'm happy happy happy to be here I
always love coming to Denver it always
freaks me out how [__] close you are
[Music]
uh I always tell myself remember there's
somebody basically sitting on stage and
I look like [__] somebody sitting on
stage it's good to see yeah man yeah
yeah you just wanted to get a good shot
of that right
there get a little that for you Hi how
are you good looking ready yeah yeah
good okay yeah um well man first of all
just a sweatshirt
[Music]
uh somebody did take it off you first
ma'am um somebody did ask me before I
get started they said hey there are a
couple of older folks out there do you
change your material for the age of the
people in front of you and uh no uh
and let me tell you why like first of
all I think it's even insulting to
ask that question they're older they're
not children but my grandmother is the
one who knocked that notion out of my
head so the first time I ever performed
in front of her I was super nervous
because I didn't want to swear in front
of her right so she catches me backstage
and she goes you look
nervous and I said I am I am nervous and
she said why are you so nervous
and I said I don't I don't want to swear
in front of you Nana and she said what
word is it you don't want to say tell me
and I
went I don't want to say [__] in front
of you and she said
sweetheart I had to [__] for you to get
here and I was
[Music]
like [__] to the show I'd have given you
a ride man oh
[__] I don't need you in the side of the
road like my grandson needs to
work [__]
up I'm so happy that I I'm in a state
where I can just put my edible on the
[__] stand right
there it's so amazing and by the way um
I'm usually a pretty active comic but
seeing as how I got winded walking a
block today that shit's not
happening I've said it a million times a
million times over and over but you guys
like when you go down to sea level do
you guys [__] fight crime and [__]
like you living up cars I'm from
Denver
[__] doing that bit I'm winded
okay uh a couple things and then we'll
get into the jokes uh anybody who's ever
seen me knows that I Ram a little bit up
top uh I
uh
okay somebody asked me a question today
I never been asked so I was on the phone
I was doing an interview with a friend
of mine gay guy and I asked him a
question I'm sure he's been asked a
million times I said uh one of the
questions was when did you know you were
gay and he told me and then we interview
and the whole thing and at the end of
the interview he said to me just had a
curiosity when when did you know you
weren't gay and I was like what
and he goes was there a moment I
go was there supposed to be a [__]
moment and then I started to think about
it I thought about it and I will tell
you I think it for most straight dudes
it's probably the same moment this is
when you realize you're not Guy is when
you're teenager and you're
masturbating and you look down at the
wrong minute and you get a little bit of
your own [__] on your face she like I
don't [__] like that at all
right dude that very first time your own
C hits your face you're like that's not
my team I'm not on that
[Music]
team pretty glad I found that [__] out
right now I'll tell you that and I I
called my brother and I told him that he
goes yeah man that happened to me twice
I go
twice yeah I knew I didn't like it
enough the first time you know what I
mean like twice that means you leaned
into it dude like h
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and okay and then I'll get into the
jokes so
uh I've spent the last couple months
trying to decide if I'm a [__] or not
and let me tell you why anybody have
like an old school father who's always
telling you about your generation a
bunch of gener generation to BU you
right so my dad's been on me so I've
been trying to take inventory on what it
means to be a man and 2017 right and I
can build some [__] and I can fix some
[__] so I feel like for dudes in 2017
that puts me over the 50th percentile
right I think so right so I'm feeling
pretty good about myself now guys I
watch all of my movies on planes because
I fly so much I don't I I just I'm on
there so much I'm like let's just see
everything so I recently a month ago I
finally watched the movie the
rant how around on the Applause people
seen the
r not a great movie to watch if you're
trying to decide how [__] tough you
are
[Music]
right now for those of you who haven't
seen it Leonardo DiCaprio set in the
frontier dude is a bad [__] he
could [__] by a bear guys like that's
not easy right you know what I mean so
I'm watching the movie and I'm like okay
what things from here do I feel good
about oh yeah I could build a fire which
I can oh I can do some hunting which I
can right I'm feeling pretty good as a
man and then there was one scene that
made me feel like such a
[__] do you guys remember that scene
you saw you remember that scene where he
eats that live bison heart you remember
that where he eats the live bison heart
and he eats it like it's the best thing
he's ever had right he's So Satisfied it
puts him to sleep blood dripping off his
beard he eat guys he eats a live [__]
bison
heart do you understand like if my
banana is too mushy I'm like I can't
[Music]
this dude laid a live [__] animal if
there's a brown spot on my banana I'm
like [__]
[Music]
that on top of that right my wife wears
yoga pants every day every day yeah
right so I said to her why do you wear
yoga pants every day and she said
they're so
comfortable and I said said how
comfortable could they
be and she said you you just got to try
them
[Music]
all don't shake your head dude I'm
telling you right now they are so
uncomfortable oh my God and your dick
looks [__] huge in those
things I couldn't believe it I was like
my dick always looks this big and she
was like no I've never seen it look like
that but it's amazing and they're so
soft nobody told us they were so soft
they're like what I thought unicorn hair
might feel like you know what I mean
like that and they're and they lift and
they support and they separate in all
the right places dude I dare you to put
them on walk 50 ft and not get a heart
on I [__] dare
you it's like a little cotton blunt hand
job across my living room was
like I came three times before I left my
house I try those [__] on lul
man like I buy that [__]
now
I will tell you one thing that's that's
been happening to me lately I would say
over the past year or two there's been a
drastic shift in my life and that shift
has been this I grew up poor and um my
dad was a cheap [__] and uh
because of that I missed out on a lot of
experiences you know and I decided about
two years ago that like you know I found
myself nickeling Diamond myself like I
wouldn't spend certain amount of money
on a concert ticket because I probably
shouldn't but then a year later I didn't
know where that $100 went and I still
didn't have the memory so I tell
everybody now look a year if you don't
decide not to go somewhere because it's
gonna spend $100 you don't think you can
afford it a year from now you'll have no
idea where that 100 bucks went but a
year from now you would have that memory
of that [__] concert so make memories
everybody make some [__] memories you
get one trip on this rock that's it so
go do some [__] so we listen there was a
concert in September that I was like
shouldn't spend that money but I was
like [__] it all six of these bands or
musicians were on my bucket list it was
uh it was called desert trip and it was
out where they do old with Coachella it
was like old Cella it was old it was
Coachella for old people it was uh did
you go so did you go guys Stones The Who
McCartney Roger Waters Neil Young and
Bob Dylan all in the same place now how
many people in here have ever seen Bob
Dylan
before yeah he sucks dick he's so bad
did he play any hits when you saw him
not one [__] hit he didn't play one
[__] hit now play Tangled Up and blue
[__] I want one hit and then
some guy next to me was like yeah but
he's Bob Dylan he's earned the right to
do what he wants and I believe that's
true if he's performing in his own
[__] living room but he
wasn't there were 90,000 people there
who paid a [__] pretty p i I will
punch you in the face you piece of beef
jerky [__] you oh you don't think I'll
fight Bob Dylan I'll fight Bob Dylan
right now be the [__] out of that dude I
just want to hit him once to hear him go
I just want to see
that oh I was mad I was mad but on the
way in right I told my brothers I'm like
hey guys I'm taking mushrooms this
weekend and they were like which night I
said did you hear me this
[Music]
weekend and they were like why are you
gonna they go you you're gonna do that
by yourself and I said no there there's
going to be 90,000 people
there and they were like you're not but
you don't know any of them I was like
well I'm I'm
gonna now okay so and by the way I did
it out of respect for the bands we were
going to see I felt like they would want
me to be [__] up right so B got a
curiosity Round of Applause and I'm
assuming this will be a larger Round of
Applause and in most cities people who
have taken mushrooms
before W
okay guys I was in Huntsville Alabama
last weekend I asked that question and
one dude goes I got some on my salad
right now and I was
like and not what I'm talking about uh
so after Dylan I was like I'm taking the
mushrooms now I'm not I'm not I'm not
putting myself through another
disappointing show now at following
Dylan was the stone and I had never seen
the stones before and so uh and by the
way sitting next to me was this old
Hispanic couple and the dude had those
like the round tiny glasses and he had a
tiny ponytail you know one of these and
it was pulled tight so dude look
surprised the whole show
like
so and she scratched his back the entire
concert sh sh sh 2 and 1 half
hours so about 5 minutes before the
music starts I get my first little warm
hug and I'm
like I'm like this is about to be the
best night of my [__] life
right and so the guy next to me he turns
to me and he goes hey man and I go hey
and he goes what's your name I said Josh
and he said who do you think the best
rock band of of all time is Josh and
listen guys I'm about to trip balls
right so the last thing I want to do is
have a conversation with the Mexican
John Lennon you know what I mean like
I'm G Pasadena on that right [__] now
right so I just tell him what I think is
going to answer the he stop most
conversation I said the Beatles and he
goes Whoa man it's the stones she and I
have seen the stone 66
[Music]
times
and she said yeah and we refall in love
every show and I was like yeah I was
like that's sweet and I said that's
going to be very cool for me to watch
the stones for the first time next to
people who have seen them 66 times and
I'm going to watch them reall in love
right in front of my face that's a belt
to melt off my [__] skull you know
what I mean
like I felt like telling them I hope you
don't mind watching this concert next to
the Ghost Rider because
[Music]
I'm not for sure what's going to happen
from here on out you
know
so I then start
in and I'm like oh my God
right I couldn't believe what was
happening not kidding 10 minutes in dude
turns to me and he goes hey man and I go
hey and he goes what's your name and I
was
like
[Music]
I said
Josh and he goes who do you think the
best rock and roll band of all time is
Josh and for a second I thought oh my
God these mushrooms are
amazing I was like this is the most
visceral Deja Vu I've ever had in my
entire life and honestly I tell I'm not
going to lie to you for a second I
thought I can see the [__] future
like I know how this conversation ends
oh I'm going to see this concert twice
[__]
yeah but we did the whole thing 66 times
refall in
love not kidding no joke 12 minutes
later dude turns to me and he goes
hey
man and I go don't you ask me that
[__] question again
dude and his wife goes to me you'll have
to excuse him
sh he's done a lot of drugs he doesn't
have any short-term memory and I was
like well no wonder you got to see the
stone 66 [__]
times and just so you know you don't
refall in love he thinks he bangs some
chick at the Stones concert every
weekend
like not as romantic CU you think it is
man I'm just
saying and I'll tell you something here
was my true privilege of that weekend
and this is no joke my true privilege
and honestly what I would tell you my
favorite thing of the weekend is to
watch a generation of people watch their
Idols for the last time was so [__]
cool guys because you watched a
generation of people party without
inhibition and they probably hadn't been
able to do that in 20 30 years do you
know what I mean no judgment they were
all there together to have a good time
and it was [__] amazing and I'll tell
you what was happening there was a lot
of old white guy dance circles popping
up now if you haven't seen one of those
uh you should
uh and when I say dance circles there's
a lot of Two Gun salutes you know what I
mean there was a guy next to me doing
the pencil I love that
one and then there was a dude big guy
doing leg kicks like this and I was like
[__] look at the big guy he was
killing too having a good time I'm doing
some of this right and then all of a
sudden big guy just [__] collapsed
and I was like oh
no he he [__] River danced himself to
death
[Music]
like this dude's not getting up no way
right older guy probably 68 he's laying
there big dude EMTs come they roll him
onto a stretcher [__] start to wheel
him out I'm like look at this old dude
terrible man for this weekend to end
like that for him and one of his friends
leans over to him right next to me and
he goes you're going to be okay man the
old dude goes
yeah I'm just
[Music]
tired and the guy said what he goes yeah
I was tired from dancing around so I
laid
down and then the EMTs came and said you
got to get up and I told him I'm not
[__] getting up I'm tired and the
guys told him if you don't get up we're
going to have to wheel you out of here
and he said that actually sounds kind of
nice so they wheeled this dude out to
take a [__] nap rock and roll
right and here's when things got a
little
weird there was like a 280 290 shirt
pound shirtless dude running up to
people doing
this and I was watching him and I'm like
oh [__] I really hope he doesn't come
over here right
he comes over and it's like a there's a
lot of there's tracers coming off of his
stomach like it's move you know when you
see a bell the belly that size and it
moves all at once so for those of you
who've done mushrooms before picture
tracers flying off with that belly I was
like oh I'm [__] stuck like
uh I was like I'm never going to watch a
band again like however long he's
shaking that [__] I'm watching
right
and then he said something to me that I
promise you has never been uttered ever
before in the history of human beings he
shakes his belly at me and he goes hey I
go what's up and he goes how many
Knuckles deep you think you can go on my
belly button I went
what and he goes how many Knuckles deep
I go none none Knuckles deep dude zero
Knuckles deep and he goes why not I go
what why not what do you mean I'm not
doing it and he goes everybody's doing
it and I was like who show me one
[__]
do he goes everybody's doing it man and
listen you guys have done mushrooms
right it's a communal thing right and I
don't want to be the only guy who
doesn't finger [__] this dude's belly
button you know what I
mean I don't want to be Debbie Downer
like that guy wouldn't finger [__] my
belly button I don't want to be that guy
you
know so I'm like yeah
man I'll do it and he goes okay and I go
what what finger should I
use what's my first time finger [__]
a dude's belly button guys like I just
want to make sure I'm doing it right you
know I'm a pleaser and
uh I don't want him to go home and be
like that dude pinked me
[Music]
uh so he said index and I go okay and it
gets
worse
so I go to lube up my finger
right and dude goes you won't need any
lube and I was
like yes what I did dude I was like
[__] lucky me okay so it
just it just slipped right in right with
room to spare and I was like well big
fella we got some room and he goes okay
and I go to pull my finger out and guys
you know when you put your finger in one
of those Chinese finger
locks and it's easy to get in but you
pull it out and it kind of clamps down
it clamped down on my finger and I was
like oh [__] no right I went full Palm
on his belly
like and it just popped out right and as
soon as it pops out he looks at me and
he goes we finally found somebody to do
it I go I thought you said everything
everybody was doing it and he goes who
would do that I go that's what I want to
[Music]
said now let's get to the honest part of
this honest if we're talking about
honesty honesty as a man as a
man I had to fight every fiber in my
body and have to smell my finger one
time not I mean don't owe me you
hypocritical [__] you graze
your nuts the first thing you do is
smell them don't [__]
you and I had a unicorn on my finger I
was never going to smell that [__] again
you know what I
mean I I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't I didn't no I did not I did no I
did not I gave my brother a dirty
Sanchez and I was like you enjoy your
[Applause]
[Music]
weekend
dirty sanchez
yeah I like your
sweatshirt I almost brought my teenage
son to that
concert I did but but I was like I
really want to do mushrooms so and if
you're asking if I pick drugs over my
son yep
uh no question he's not as much fun as
mushrooms I'm telling you that right
now I I will tell you though he tells me
absolutely everything he told me that uh
that he smoked weed and um was so funny
we were out walking my dog when he told
me and he goes to me he goes
hey I just want you to
know I smoke
weed and I said okay
man
um what can we talk about this when I'm
not high
[Music]
yeah I don't know what to tell you
except stay out of my top drawer that's
all I can tell
[Music]
you you know medical marijuana is so
easy to get in La I know you guys get
wreck it's so in other parts of the
country it's so hard in La it's so easy
let me tell you I went into the doctor's
office right with this whole story
planned I remember and you didn't need
it on the wall in the lobby is a poster
that has all the list of any symptom you
could have where he would give you the
script it's a cheat sheet right all you
got to do is say one of those words so I
was like oh that's easy right and you
ever do this I walk in it was an
alphabetical and I go I'm just going to
memorize the first
one got
it what the [__] was that again right
I so I I I thought I had it alphabetical
first one and uh I go into the doctor's
office and uh he sits down and he goes
uh Mr Wolf so what are your symptoms
what how can we help you you feel like
you need medical marijuana and I just
blanked but I remembered it was the
first one so I was
like
autism and he was
[Music]
he said you mean anxiety I go that's it
anxiety I got
anxiety I'm scared I'm going to get
autism sometime can you just give me my
[__] card
please
my he does tell me everything man he
told me the first time he touched the
boob crazy he comes home serious as
[__] comes home me walks into my room
he's like
[Music]
hey I said what's going on and he
goes I walk up to him I go what's up he
goes no no no no
no
outside now when he said outside I'll
tell you what I thought was happening
what I thought was happening was I
thought he had hit that point in time in
his life that every man hits where they
look at their dad that very first time
and they think to
themselves oh I could beat the [__] out
of this
dude right
now not every guy does it but you look
at your dad at least once like oh tell
me to take out the trash again tell me
to take out the [__] trash again
right so we were walking outside I was
tightening up my two shoelaces on like
like oh it's [__] on okay here we go
right and I was planning on just poking
my neck once really hard to slow him
down so we could talk a little bit you
know where he can catch his breath and
we could talk
right and we get outside and he's
like touch the
boob and I go yeah what do you think he
goes well I'm definitely going to try to
do that
again did anybody in here any gu guy in
here wrestle or fight their dad anybody
you did how old were you when you did it
how old were
you years ago seven years
ago H how old are you dude 38 that's
just beating up an old man at that point
in
time get out of the chair old man God
can't get out of your [__]
chair
well you got to go you got to go in when
you think you get a shot that's all I'm
saying
so how it go for you I hope you won join
the Army after that you what join the
Army oh you join the
Army after you beat up your dad you
joined the
[Music]
army why is he buried somewhere where
you
needed somebody going to find this body
soon soon I gu join the Army I guess
uh did anybody else not go into the old
person's home and drag their dad out by
the [__]
neck anybody else fight or wrestle their
dad anybody else how how old were you
man how old were you I was like seven
years old seven years
old what the [__] is with you
to you know not a lot of muscle tone
when you're seven you know what I mean
to be grow who you up with Michael
Jackson what the [__]
dude 7 years
old how did that go for you he was my
stepfather and he was an alcoholic oh
got it got it it well now I feel like an
[__]
[Music]
no that's dick let's get back into this
guy right what a
[Laughter]
[Music]
dick did anybody else
not a [__] child and not an old
person 11 that's still young too you you
bad [__] up here
huh uh and how'd it go for you at 11 not
that well huh my dad was huge compared
to me yeah because you were 11 dude
every grown-up is
[Music]
you I thought I like be a [__] trip him
oh you tried to trip him when he was
down yeah so you're you're you're you're
whole strategy was to trip the the
grownup and and hit him when he was
down that didn't go that well for you
did it no heads to the wall yeah yeah
yeah hard to trip a grownup at 11
yeah now listen I grew up with three
older brothers we all went at my dad at
one point in time but you know we did it
when we were
[Laughter]
[Music]
teenagers so we
didn't we
did we didn't knock the Metamucil out of
his hands and [__] beat the [__] out
him put your teeth back in so I can
knock those out
again
I remember so me and my two brothers
were in my room playing and we were all
under the age of 10 I was probably about
six and my oldest brother was about 14
and none of us had ever thought about
fighting or wrestling my dad before
that's not something that we you know
what I mean and so I was out of nowhere
and I don't my brother just walks in
confident to the room he walks in and he
goes I'm fighting dad
today
and we were like you fighting
dad and he was like that's right I'm
fighting
dad you guys got my back and we were
like f yeah we got your
back and he goes you guys ready like
yeah we're ready we're going ready and
he goes there's going to be some new
rules after today and we were like yeah
new rules [__] that guy I'm eating
cereal for dinner [__] Fu am right we
were going crazy Oh I thought there was
going to be a regime change guys I
needed to be on the right side of that
[__] right oh he was Ring us up
we were walking down the stairs I was
grabbing pictures of my dad off the
wall oh it was low of the Flies in that
[__] right we were [__] going crazy
he was like let's go and like yeah here
we go right so my dad's out on the patio
and my brother walks outside and he goes
and my dad's smoking a cigar my brother
walks outside and he goes
we're fighting today old
man my dad stands up and he
goes
okay now in
hindsight my dad's confidence should
have been a bit of a red flag for my
[Music]
brother because that dude didn't even
take the [__] cigar out of his
mouth so he knew he wasn't getting hit
you know what I mean he was like yeah
okay and my brother goes and let me tell
you something and before he could get
another word out of his [__]
mouth my dad kicked him in the nuts so
hard he was like
uhuh and he fell on the ground and my
dad just walked up to him and goes you
know you shouldn't talk when you fight
right and walked in the house like a
[__]
gangster and we all walk by I'm like
yeah you shouldn't talk with your
F oh I'm not hanging outside with the
loser I got to go outside with the
winner
like but it's not a problem like that
wrestle for
for for power in the house happens with
boys it didn't happen with my daughter
it was a different struggle like
um I generally don't understand like a
word that's coming out of her
mouth that's the problem like we'll be
in my living room and she'll be
like my god daddy okay Daddy okay Daddy
oh my
God
I'm
I'm it's like having a [__] dolphin
in my living
room and I she tells me everything too
right I remember one time she came home
and she was like oh my god daddy I have
to tell you something so important
daddy oh my god daddy okay Daddy okay
Daddy okay Daddy I'm get Daddy okay
Daddy I'm get Daddy okay Daddy I'm get
Daddy okay okay Daddy I'm get Daddy okay
Daddy I'm get Daddy okay
Daddy I'm my get Daddy I'm good daddy
okay Chris tried to kiss
me and I said uh
oh my
[Music]
God I said uh I said what happened babe
and she said I'm get
[Music]
that I told him I wasn't sure if I was
allowed to do that I had to go home and
ask my
daddy and I was like you know what baby
thank you very much for asking look I
know you're a teenager and your hormones
are raging I know you're very curious
and I'm not going to tell tell you what
to do and what not to do I don't think
that's my job as your father my job as
your father is just to tell you what I
know and what I know is is
that God doesn't let little hookers into
[Music]
[Applause]
heaven do whatever you want to do with
that information
babe you think I want her hanging around
teenage boys guys and here's the thing I
know some of you are like is it a double
standard with your son or your daughter
[__] at it yeah I will proudly tell you
that and listen unapologetically cuz
young men are [__]
Savages and it's not their fault but
they're Savages they're [__] one guys
look when a part of your body for five
years of your life acts on its own
accord when a part of your body for no
reason during math classes like let's
get up you're like what
[__] I remember being in math class
looking around like and my teacher used
to think I was cheating I was just
seeing if anybody else was hard I'm like
[Laughter]
[Music]
what I guess nobody likes geometry as
much as I
[Laughter]
do
but yeah here's here's my best example
of why uh uh young men are just
worse than young women okay here's the
best example I can give you and why
they're just
animals when I was younger I used to
play a game called hang brains does
anybody know what hang brains is you do
so uh and listen guys your nut sack when
it just hangs out of your pants looks
like a brain
so we used to play a game called hang
brains where three of us would walk into
a bar and the last person who got his
nut sack noticed got free drinks for a
night now I know it sounds stupid stupid
stupid but I'm telling you something
right now so [__] funny uh it just
looks like the three dudes have like
like a pack of Big League chews stuck to
their [__] jeans it's so funny
uh and here's the thing
here's why it's different not only is
the fact that I that as a man we think
that's funny but I'm telling you guys
right now I have gone 17 minutes in a
crowded
bar because women when we walk into a
bar the first thing you do isn't look at
our nuts because you're not [__]
animals
okay you're not now eventually
somebody's like his nuts are out right
or and I'm going to tell you the truth
most of the time you know who noticed a
dude hey bro you're [__] nuts her
[Music]
out not a woman a
dude conversely if a woman walked in
here right now in this dark room with
you
okay right if a woman walked in here
right now dark room you can barely see
anything but if she walked in here and
she had a
16th of an inch of an areola showing
forget that if it was like a sha an
areola
Shadow if there was a sha I'm going to
if there was a mole touching the
areola so if there was a mola
[Music]
right if they oh we don't even need to
see the arola we just need to know
something is touching the areola and we
can see that if a woman walked in here
with a Moola within 7 Seconds every dude
in here would be like you see that
[__] Mariola that just walked in here
you see that Bola cuzz we're Savages
dick out nothing mola dark room every
dude's like oh my God I'm gonna jerk off
you on Moola tonight like some dude's
gonna go home and Google mola right
tonight I guarantee you just in case
it's on PornHub he's going to be like
I'll take a look I'm not
I'm
animals and that's why I don't want my
daughter
like no it's not it's
not okay here's the best like my son is
a teenager okay in like who has teenage
boys in here
anybody so first of all how [__]
gross are
they his room smells like he's been
baking feet in there for [__] two
weeks it's like feet with onions and
semen sprinkled on top that's what his
room you walk into his room you're like
what's up [__] what's up [__] and you
know what happened to me the grossest
thing I'm walking to his bed the other
day I'm like hey man he goes oh don't
step on that sock I was like [__]
you I mean put your nut rag under your
bed like the rest of us right it looked
like someone had a pencil under a sock
right and he was like it's my room I
don't [__] care if it's your room
like I don't want the bottom of my foot
to get pregnant like but
like they're so gross and they're dumb
my son okay all right and then we'll we
got to move on cuz I want to sing One
new song my son ready for this so he's
not super bright and um and uh at my
house cleaning out the trash is one of
my jobs so I go into his room to empty
the trash can and there's 12 rubber
wrappers and rubbers in
there and I go yeah that's the look I
had too I was like that's a good week's
work right
there definitely a teenager my age I'm
like listen you can hold on to those
other eight because uh that's not happen
so I call him in I go hey man and he's
like
yeah I go first of all I thought we were
going to talk before you had sex and he
goes no no no we are it's it's something
completely different and I was
like I was like what he goes well if you
must
know
I think I'm going to have sex soon so
I'm just practicing putting them on and
taking them
off and I said dude why are you doing
that and he goes Dad I've never had sex
before I don't want it to take so long
where I give her a chance where she
could change your
[Music]
mind I was like you know what dude
you're not that stupid that's pretty
smart
[Music]
actually now somebody asked me to tell
the story so I certainly will um uh I
have a favorite practical joke um I love
practical jokes they're like my favorite
thing to do to people um I like being
the recipient too like a good practical
joke I'm on board for that [__] too uh
and my kids know that I scare Easy by
the way I scare my kids and pull
practical jokes on them I I want you to
know that I I scare easy I'm a jazz
hander my daughter has more videos of me
doing this a [__]
[Music]
you cuz my always an and follows with
the [__]
you cuz I try to get a little more manly
after my [__]
you
so I love practical jokes this is my
best one ever my buddy asked me to throw
him a bachelor party and I was like man
you don't want me to do that I said I'm
a comedian I always go for the laugh and
then I hope we can shake hands and be
friends later but I'm going to [__] up
your
day and he was like I don't think you'll
do that I said I don't think you're
listening I'm already trying to decide
how to [__] with you
so can we just like uh not have me do it
he was like buddy you've been to Vegas
more than any of us you plan the party
you get the girl now look I got him a
girl for the end of his party that's
what he wanted a stripper I'm not a
stripper guy I never have been a
stripper guy I don't really care but he
wanted a stripper at the end of his
party that's cool I wanted the beginning
of the party to be for
me and what did I want to watch what do
I like way more than strippers I like
weird [__] I guys if you're like hey man
this is about to be some weird [__]
happening in alley I'll be like I'm gon
[__] watch
that 100% I love it how weird I wanted
people walking out of his party like
this what the [__] just happened in
there like was some guy walking out with
a limp like why are my hands dirty like
weird [__]
right where did I think I could find
that I went on Craigslist in
Vegas oh guys I have never felt so horny
and sad at the same time in my entire
life scrolling through scrolling through
it's all sex stuff I don't want that I
want weird and then weird jumped out the
screen of Me This Woman's advertisement
was three words that's it and those
three words
were I'll wrestle you and I was like
[__] yeah you
will that at least deserves a phone call
I think
right I call her on the phone she is 6'
250 and her special skill is that she'll
come over to your house she'll get naked
and she'll toss you around for a little
[Laughter]
while and I was like well what time can
you get
[Music]
here so she shows up and I open the door
and she's legitimate 6' 250 right and
she's holding a foot long Sub in 24
buffalo
wings not kidding and she waves him in
my face and she goes you got a room
where I could go fuel up before the
match and I was
like first of all [__] yes I do right in
there and I said second of all you
should
know that the person you're wrestling
today doesn't know there's going to be a
match you know I don't know if that
Chang changes your professional Approach
at
all so she goes off into her room my
buddy comes over and we've got him on a
stool just like this one and um my other
friends are standing behind him and we
got him blindfolded and he's well I
don't want to ruin the surprise you know
and he's like oh this chair is one Ralph
you may away from an accident I'll tell
you that right
now
oh you don't think he knows he's 900 lb
he [__]
knows look at this so
um he's sitting there and he's
like I'm so excited and I was
like me
[Music]
too and he says I'm ready and I said
okay and I call her out now none of my
other friends knew what I had
planned so when she walked out of that
room
naked collectively they were like what
the
[__] and as she got closer I saw she
still had Buffalo Wings sawce around
her I was going to get her a napkin but
I was like I'm sorry that [__] is too
funny on your face I am so
sorry so she stands in front of him 6'
250 oh I forgot to tell you the best
part my buddy
58 and 140 and like a like a like aooo
like a soft 140 right so the size
difference alone like I don't know
what's going to happen but I'm pretty
sure I'm going to [__] like
[Music]
it and he says I'm ready and I said okay
and I take off his blindfold and the
only
word he could get out of his mouth
before she ripped him out of his
[Music]
chair
was why
[Music]
right and she lifted him up like this
his little feet were dangling in the air
she started to toss him around the room
like a ragd doll and we were all
like guys she would jump on top of him
and he had to push her fat out of his
face to talk to us he would be like tell
her to
stop how long she going to be here I
can't
breathe why does she smell like buffalo
wings
[Music]
right there was one time where she was
straddling him like this beating him in
the face with her titties
just I don't think you're getting the
right visual okay
uh guys this isn't 5'2 110 10B [__] [__]
titties this is 6 foot
[Music]
just titties that's how biger titties
were they made that noise through the
air it was like being hit with a tit
missile
just dude had a swollen eye from titty
punches you've never seen that in the
history of [__] never ever I'll tell
you that right
now so she thinks her job is done right
she walks over here to this side to the
room my buddy gets up mad you know when
you can tell someone that's mad where
they never take their eyes off of that
thing they're mad at so he gets up and
he walks away from her like
[Music]
this and then something minum just
snapped and he just looks at her and he
goes I'm GNA [__] you
up and like a wave of calm crashed over
her like serious like Bruce Lee Enter
the Dragon commom she was just
like and they ran at each
other guys do you understand what's
happening they're [__] fighting for
real
now it's the best gift I've ever given
to myself ever are you kidding me
they're running at each other I'm like I
don't even know how this is going to end
oh my God they're running at each other
and my buddy was mad and he screamed I
want to take you
down running at each other full speed
and he ran into her I'm G to tell you
something he really did try to take her
down I'll tell you what he did
not all I can tell you is that when his
little body hit
hers she kind of absorbed him for a
second
and he disappeared I was like where the
[__] did he go and then she just shot
him out across the room boom and he slid
on the floor and one of my friends ran
up to him and went that just [__]
happened to
[Music]
you and she was mad that he challenged
her or something so she goes to us you
want to see my finishing move you want
me to finish him and I grew up with Hulk
Hogan and Rand into the Macho Man Savage
so I was like you [__]
finish
I didn't know if she was coming off the
top rope or dropping a leg or whatever I
wanted to see that [__] right so she
starts to run to him and she was like
finish him and we go yeah she goes
finishing move and we go yeah and she
goes you want to see the finishing move
and we go yeah and then she sat on his
head and we went
no not that finishing move [__] guys his
little head
disappeared all you could see were his
tiny arm slapping her back like
this oh it was a fight for life I'm
telling you that right now it was the
weirdest [__] I've ever seen it was like
a reverse birth it was [__] up that's
all I'll
say and here's how you know you pulled a
good practical
joke a good practical joke is a joke
that continues to pay dividends long
after the joke is
over so like a month and a half after
the wedding after the uh uh uh party two
weeks before the wedding I ran into his
dad and his dad goes uh Hey you're not
coming to the wedding I was uninvited to
The Wedding by the way
uh totally worth it totally worth it you
guys want to see how he Uninvited me
this is my favorite part this is how he
United
me she just got off of him and he stands
up and he
goes you're not coming to the
wedding so here's how his dad goes you
know come to the wedding I go no and he
goes why not and I said oh
uh Tim didn't tell you
and he said no and I go
uh well do you got a couple minutes sit
down sit
down and then his dad used that story as
his best man speech at the
what [__] winner
winner all right let's play a couple
songs and let's get you out of here all
right all right all right now listen I
want to be honest with you I'm not a
good guitar player I play twice a week
seven minutes at a time
um but I'm gonna play One new song and
guys just like the rest of my ACT uh you
know I tell people all the time hey you
come to the show tonight I I hope you're
not expecting to learn anything like uh
my my shows are just supposed to be fun
right and these and these this these
songs are just silly and fun so I hope
you like them um and uh while I set up I
do this all the time while I set up if
anybody has any questions about anything
I've ever done anybody I've ever worked
with now would be the time to do it so
we're ready to sing anybody any
questions where live what's that where
do I
live does anybody have any non creepy
questions
or I live in California I live in
California
California how's working with Chelsea
how's working with Chelsea uh people ask
me that a lot listen you know it depends
on who you
are because I like I said three older
brothers so honesty doesn't doesn't
bother me and honesty repeatedly in your
[__] face it doesn't bother me what
she holds she holds maybe the three most
important characteristics that I look
for in people which is honesty loyalty
and generosity and she has all three of
those in Spade so for me for me working
with her was great for some people that
Honesty was a little too
much look I not kidding right now I
probably weigh it doesn't matter what I
weigh but I was uh
I was
194 PBS and um I'm walking up the stairs
in front of her at work and I didn't
know she was behind me and all I hear is
[__]
[Music]
gross and I turn around I go what's up
she goes your ass is [__]
gross I go what are you talking about
she goes it's all [__]
unorganized and I was like well I guess
I'll lose some weight that's a good idea
okay uh anybody else want a beer do I
want a beer I I huh did you say relax
yes yes you
do p
for I I will tell you what I would drink
a shot of
[Applause]
tequila but that yeah but that just
means somebody has to be willing to get
pregnant
[Music]
uh and other any other questions before
we get
going uh who's my favorite
comedian all time or right
now Sam Kennison all time uh I would
probably say because I know him so well
and I know from you know the journey is
so important to me and so knowing where
he started and knowing what he's been
through to where he is now uh for me
it's Joey
[Applause]
Diaz you know if you don't know his
story it's it's pretty remarkable so
yeah for me it's Joey and one more what
you what was that your shirt doesn't
mean something my shirt doesn't mean
something it it just it means uh it
means I sweat on stage so I wear black
shirts oh thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you you know what's funny you know you
have a good job when you do a shot and
people are like
yay yay he's drinking
yay [__] great job um all right so
this song is new it's the first time
I've ever played it without a um
notebook so we'll see what happens um
and then I'll do one other song and
because I'm G to run a little late
here's what I'd ask you guys to do um
Round of Applause people who have waited
tables before
good all right so I don't have to tell
you I'm preaching to the choir but I do
not sell merch at my shows the reason I
don't is because I always ask people to
spend if you were going to spend any
extra to spend it on your weight staff
whenever I see rooms like this
right as a waiter or waitress when I
would walk into a room like this I could
I would be like oh this tonight I could
pay rent with tonight you remember those
nights when you waited tables you were
like oh this is a [__] rent night so
what I always ask people is just so you
know 15% is not acceptable that happened
to 1984 it's not a livable percent
anymore it's got to be 20 and go up from
there but I would ask you guys this and
just remember this if everybody in here
left an extra at least $2 not per table
not per tab per person how many times
can you say you spent $2 and you made
somebody's night you would make
somebody's night if everybody in here
spent an extra $2 the weight staff would
leave here like oh my God this was the
best night of my life guys that's the
ability you have with $2 so let's let's
uh let's all tip the weight St a little
extra all right
and also after the show where do we do
pictures upstairs all right so guys I'll
be up there a couple minutes uh and uh
you g to let me going back and change my
shirt and get a little higher and then I
will uh and then I'll see you up there
and wait for me and uh all that stuff
all right so this song I wrote uh
started writing around Valentine's
Day because uh uh my wife just puts too
much time and effort into gifts and I
keep telling her it's pretty easy like
you're out thinking yourself on Father's
Day and on my birthday and and any other
time you give me a gift it's pretty
simple so this song is not only for my
wife but it's for
anybody who's looking to get a gift for
that special man in their life um and
this pretty much covers I think
everybody um and this it's simple and
easy and you can do it anytime you
want
it's what you're thinking but there's a
Twist Again not a good guitar player
we'll see what
happens
okay you're always so
thoughtful gifts on my special
[Music]
day asking friends and
family about things that make me feel
great let let me try to help
you Let Me ease your
mind cuz it's pretty
easy I just like a blow job and a
sandwich let me save you some time I
want a blowj job and a sandwich I don't
need another [__] tie and I haven't
worn cologne since the eighth grade you
and your sister used a couple's massage
M I want a blowj job and a
sandwich at the same
time at the same
time timey timey timey timey timey timey
time I like turkey on
wheat
I like ham on
right to make your day complete though
there's one more thing that I'd like to
try now I know when guys say
try women always think that we're
talking about
anal and that's
true but not this
time I just like a blue job and a
sandwich while I'm watching
TV turn on
ESPN March
Madness watching Men dribble balls up
and down the
[Music]
court now I know on your special
day I'd give you anything that you
need trips jewelry or clothing I'd bring
the moon down to its
knees but you don't have to tell
me I know what you really
want you want my naked or washing
dishes
in a Ryan Gosling
mask rowing boats in the
rain telling all of my
friends quotes from The Notebook over
again I wrote her every single
[Music]
day
anybody know what the guns what end of
The Guns of Rosa song that
[Music]
was
patience I don't know if my voice if
I'll be able to do this in the altitude
but let's
[Music]
see all
right [__] and a
sandwich
yeah blow
yeah a [__] and a I just want to blow
job and a
sandwich while I watch TV in bed I
promise not to get any crumbs on your
head I just want to blow J while I watch
some
TV that'll feel so fine to me in a blow
job yay a
sandwich
blow
s
yeah
thank you very
much all right let's do one more we're g
to tip our weight
Stu yeah good okay one
more all right um so uh [__] okay
uh wait step Don't HTE me okay here we
go uh I did this song I I I wrote the
song after I talked to this girl I went
to high school with
and I remembered when we were in high
school we had decided we were going to
be each other's firsts because we were
the last two virgins that we
knew and uh I remember when we were in
high school I called her I was like you
know what we should be each other's
first like cuz I we went to preschool
together so I've known you forever like
you can't do anything to embarrass
yourself in front of me I can't
embarrass myself in front of you let's
be each other's first and she said you
know what that's a great idea we're
gonna be each other's first this is GNA
be a magical night
and this song is how that night
went and said I'd be your first and
you'd be
mine we'd be together until the end of
time I laid her down and I kissed her
lips jeans on jeans and hips on hips
well things were going just as we
planned she was my girl and I was her
man yeah right before we began will
I came in my
pants I came right in my pants well
please don't tell my
friends that I came in my
pants and she was good to
me said it could happen to
anyone she said she'd give it a second
try she called the first one a dry
[Music]
run I set the mood just
right and to make sure when happened
last night didn't happen again I jerked
off four times before she came
over and then I jerked off two more
times cuz I was a teenager and I could
do that back then and it [__] felt
great I wish there were more guys in
here cuz they would get
that and she looks so
pretty she unbutton my jeans no mess
Hello
Kitty yeah and then my hand brushed her
titty and I came on her
pants I came on her lime green pants
what the [__] is going on I'll never see
a vagina at this rate yeah years went
by and we talk from time to time I met
her husband at the
reunion I really liked him he was a nice
[Music]
guy he and I were about eight drinks
in don't get ahead of me now don't get
ahead of me don't get ahead of
[Music]
me
when he smiled and he
said you know
man I got to tell you and he said with a
grin I know you came in your
pants and now you came on her pants too
you know she SS all her
friends the guy on TV came in his pants
she start started a Facebook
page and it's called sticky drawers
where you can tell funny stories about
sex oh and believe me she's told
yours I wanted to Revenge I didn't know
what to
do we all got drunk and ended up in my
room they passed out first
just that's a rookie
move so
I came on her
pants and then I came on his pants too
and put that on your Facebook
page with a big old [__]
you
[Music]
guys I got to go meet me upstairs I had
a really good time with you tonight
thank you very much we'll see you next
time good
[Applause]
night oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey man
you know me I have an ADHD brain I'm
fidgety that's just kind of the person I
am so I know if I'm on stage with no hat
on I'm going to be running my hand
through my hair every 37 seconds and
that's going to get distracting do you
know what I'm saying yeah but I think
you should run it through that Luscious
Hair people going to like that yeah but
I and then slowmo it but it's going to
bug me knowing I'm doing it every 35
seconds you should run your hand through
your hair in slow motion and then I I'll
have the DJ play oh yeah hey man hey
man yeah hey man hey
man hey man so we you are a Sasquatch
guy I'm a crypted guy or cryptoid guy
whatever you want to call it the crypted
and cryptoid I don't think the sasw just
technically oh know technically crypted
you know what I'm talking about know
what a crypted is so a crypted is like a
skinwalker or a moth man or the chacra
or Legend mythical but they're called
Crypt so for me I'm a big crypto guy you
know why cuz why the [__] not I'm in a
shirt that says let's summon demons um
and it's got pentagrams all over it and
I'm also in a Winnie the Pooh uh
headband Theo the Poo the Poo the Poo
the Poo the Poo the Poo the
[Music]
Poo we need the we need the we need the
hey man
oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
[Music]
man